we're doing standard
don't judge me
village of shadows long ago a young girl
went with her mother to pick berries for
her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark cold silence
the bushes empty yet determined to find
the berries
the rescue broke free from mother's
grasp and vanished into the trees
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine and under branch and into the
forest deep
feeling strange eyes upon her the girl
recalled mother's scary bedtime tales
and her throat became bone dry
then this animation beautiful he greeted
her warmly and
bit his own wing come child quench your
thirst he said
so she drank the thick dark blood and
smiled with you some of my dog
passing through the graveyard menacing
storm clouds loomed
and the air turned bitingly cold the
girl was shivering in her thin
clothes then a dark weaver appeared and
with a clip of his fingers
crafted mist into a beautiful dress
come child warm yourself he coaxed
so she clothed herself and smiled with
joy
across waters deep and ominous she went
hoping a boat she found would carry her
home
but hunger's grip tightened and her
heart grew heavy
this is so beautiful the fish king
appeared
and offered one of his many fins come
child
eat your fill so the girl ate
and smiled with joy once more
continuing on she soon entered the
forest
dark heart then an iron steed appeared
bearing a beautiful golden gear
the creature said nothing as the girl
approached and snatched
what she thought it might seem like
caroline
the horse grew angry and summoned the
other monsters
terror filled the girl's heart as the
wild wind rose around the beast
a witch appeared dark yet regal
gifts we gave but more you took she
snarled
so more in turn is due in a blink
the girl was trapped inside a mirror
is it sweaty this type of hair [ __ ] you
should be reading your baby
what is with the creepy story she's only
six months old
yeah i'm glad i'm glad he's traditional
a local tale besides
rose doesn't seem to mind because she
doesn't understand it
thank god we moved here so that she
wouldn't have to deal with any of that
remember
there's nothing wrong with my memory
you're just being paranoid it's not i'm
still scared if
i i'm sorry but i'm not paranoid i'm
just cautious
then go cautiously take your daughter to
bed
i'll finish dinner
it's okay rose your mother doesn't want
to remember it i can't blame her
okay so did you say something this is
absolutely put her down
after what happened in rezzy seven there
was a little
um a little video like before this but i
actually
didn't watch it because i i freaked out
and i was like no i need to watch this
with you guys and now i
i don't think i can watch it again took
forever to pick these wipes okay thanks
thanks for telling me that i need to
know that
hey bubba
greenery in here this is goals for a
house
i need to get my greenery game up damn
they got like a
tree in here
what's she making what's for dinner
got you another new book abc's
at least that one's not a creepy story
[Music]
that make a great dad no maybe later
then
no i think she's don't get too close to
me when i'm cooking babe
why are you so aggressive what's wrong
with you
hey what are you doing mister okay
that's more playful
that that's good hurry up and put rose
to sleep will you
i am ah
they're there it's like i said to your
mom that book's too scary for you
yeah i agree
your mama and i love this song so much
we actually did do a little dance for
the baby that's cute
almost there honey wait no i don't want
to be almost there i want to look around
first i can probably look around after i
do this but
i'm a very annoying person i need to see
every section of
every part of the game
there's so many plants here i'm
absolutely in love hello why do i even
keep this around
i should get rid of it someday yeah we
need to uh smashy smashy
there's a storage room how to do a deep
clean before rose starts walking around
i can hear her little sniffles
curtain closes on the dole v gas
incident
the committee completed that
investigation to the 18th
on the 18th of the into the dull the
toxic gas leak
okay in louisiana they concluded the
natural deaths were caused by a leak of
natural gas
that had built up in
the job area jack baker and his family
who were exposed to the gas
perished ethan winters and his wife were
also believed to be
have been nearby but their current
whereabouts are unknown
the entire area has been closed up by
officials who believe
okay so they they said it was a freaking
gas thing
this already crazy
i don't believe they're dead
that was cool was that a police car just
going by that's cool you don't really
hear stuff like that in games
i just see odd noise that only happens
every now and then
it's always you know stuff on a loop
like that music
here's wow is this room all for you
no no no this is our room and you you're
in here
okay i'll put you down now
there you go sweetheart don't you worry
i'll be right downstairs daddy won't let
those weird fairytale monsters get you
oh he's so such a little cutie
okay we can walk a little bit faster now
what's on here mia and i had another
fight i accidentally mentioned
what happened three years ago and she
blew up at me we finally settle down in
our new life in europe and can bring
rose up properly
but i still feel like a part of me is
trapped in that hellhole back in losi
louisiana
honor i know mia doesn't like to talk
about it
but can we really just forget everything
and pretend it didn't happen
shouldn't we face what happened there so
we can live ourselves
our lives with rose without it hanging
over our heads we owe her that much at
least
i know mia knows this too she wouldn't
have exploded like that
at the hospital she didn't care
so mia's just kind of buried it under
the rug she doesn't
want to think about i mean i i get why
she was uh she wasn't a paranoid
literal monster
are there just loads of these random
picture books around because i remember
seeing one in the demo
i mean it's quite cool
it's a good place to put in some story
for those who want to see this forever
posing baby
okay i think that's everything in this
room
oh
oh rose screenings hearing vision touch
reflex test
all results show no issues she's in good
health
results found additional fungal pathogen
tests
oh right okay
oh they're not there
rose is fine
oh man she might have some weird
alteration some fungal thing
left over from what mia had oh that'd be
so strange
no monsters in the wardrobe
okay i'm back
what's dinner
is she okay sleeping like uh well like a
baby
hmm that smells good what's that oh
hands off mister
it's chubba de la gum it's a local
recipe
wow you've gone full native haven't you
local wine too don't trust her but if
you're gonna keep sulking all evening
maybe you shouldn't have any he's not
sulking you really have
to stop worrying
it's just finding you in louisiana the
pregnancy
chris moving us here military training
it all happened so fast
you know well at least we're all
together
you me rose
now everything's going seriously i think
we can just forget about what happened
in louisiana
it happened so long ago i just i don't
understand why you are so
oh
mia get down
she's not even phased she was not even
phased by that initial gunshot
and she's still acting free
i'd be screaming the house now
oh god
chris what the hell sorry ethan
no what
i mean she definitely wasn't fully cured
there's no way she would have still been
alive by then
and chris knew that
rose what the hell are you doing with my
daughter package secured
sorry package take him away
ethan no
bad boy ethan but
[Music]
hey doc hello mr winters i get your
daughter's results back and i'd like you
to come in to talk about them
how about the next day
she'll see us next week
hey now think positively all right
we talked about this i know
we hardly talk about anything else
i keep telling you it's not rose that
i'm worried about
well then what are you worried about
look
she's going to be fine i just know it
what else matters
we matter ethan you
matter you just missed me what are you
talking about
is there something you're not telling me
come on talk to me
damn it i have to take this
so their relationship was falling apart
my little angel
yeah i wish people could just
communicate more in this game and in
real life like why aren't people
communicating jesus
what happened here
who's that i didn't see the name
oh it's christmas crosstalk horse chris
redfield
then rose
what the hell happened to you
where the hell am i i'm not even in my
house anymore
oh yeah i got knocked out so oh my gosh
can i what control time game tell me how
to do the things
how do i here we go oh i can't even get
in there anyway
are you okay no you are not
okay
eliminate the target recover the body
secure rosemary winters
and ethan winters move to
the two winters winters the two winter
scissors
wouldn't that be like winters with an
apostrophe after it
not winters is it would be winters with
the depo
stop being a grammy nazi to sightsee
for further investigation at these two
transport officers to accompany them
i just remember like that used to be
really confusing for me in english class
in school and i'd always get confused by
it
um yeah the phone is useless
huh
taking off my hat until i meet lady d
oh i totally forgot i was still
crouching
okay so how do i run game will you tell
me how to run
gosh i can hardly see anything
ugh
okay i'm not alone but it might be
wolves
i mean there are werewolves in this game
possibly
well
spooky rocks
uh dead crows just hanging about
jesus christ what the freak
hmm
i don't like that i can literally hardly
see any
i just see i can see half of what's on
the screen
hello
this way
come on then
guess i don't want to use that break for
anything
ethan preserving water
oh gosh okay there's pills here
they look like the same type of pills
that were
on the bathroom side
are we going to run into mia here
[Music]
i don't believe she died
doesn't look like here today
oh great i've only just noticed there's
blood on the floor
hey foxy i see you there
oh there's a lot of uh stuffed animals
and the lady
let's go
some reason i can see more down here
than i could up there
someone's uh very anxious of uh vampires
oh wait no i forgot there are vampires
in this game
of course people would be wary of them
thought i was making a joke
jesus
okay
oops oh what is that
that looks like a like a baby like a
fetus
just a wittle mouse how did a mouse make
this much blood though
well now what
uh is the game really not gonna tell me
how to run yet
is it not left it down
what
we're crawling in with the blood all
right
what did all this
right so this has got to be the um the
werewolves isn't it
did they leave me anything and like any
goodies
did they leave anything in here no they
didn't they don't leave me any goodies
okay
yeah that's
where the hell am i
that's a cool shot i love this what a
nice establishing shot
hmm that's not good
oh my gosh and thanks for following
circs
those are big eggs what kind of eggs do
you think they are
they're bigger than your average egg i
swear they are
where i'm from anyway i don't know where
you're from
where should i go i mean definitely into
the house
but let me just have a look up here
first
orange juice
thanks for following one ringed angel
maybe
maybe they're out
i keep seeing things that remind me of
mia but then it's just a pot with
food in it so
be so distrusting
there's definitely a struggle in here
thanks for following fusion v20
so many followers that jesus picture
again
is it jesus is that blasphemy can i not
say that
that religious picture again
no one's actually in there okay good
anything
for me to pick up or anything for me to
use no just bloody things and scary
spooky stuff
okay
what the frick i think i just missed
something
i saw in the corner of my eye
so
what happened
i don't know ah i didn't realize there
was a goat's head just hanging there and
shouldn't really hang out there should i
really it's not a nice place to be
what how there's no one here this is an
abandoned
that house symbol is everywhere
or is there something up there oh
a toilet amazing
so easy please you know what it's not
actually as many options as i thought it
was
but i still i'll still hand it to them i
like it when games do that when
it's still very linear but they um
the level design is laid out in a way
where you feel like you have many
options even though you don't
and they all end up back on the same
path which is
lovely
locked due to missing homeowner
if they're missing then surely they
won't mind if i just
step inside
okay i'm coming in
go on ethan you know what to do whack it
oh
maybe this is when i find my trusty
knife
yeah called it
that's nice that's nice it's very nice
did they just run out of the house
seems like everyone was cooking at the
time that they disappeared
maybe there's a uh
maybe it's a clue
no no i'm friendly friendly
who are you who's not tree nobody there
was an accident down the road
what's going on
[Applause]
[Music]
oh brilliantly you drew them closer
even though ethan doesn't even know what
they are yet
coming who is what the hell was that
do you have a gun what please tell me i
have a gun
no why would i i have a knife your knife
[Music]
are you listening
oh should it just
dead buddy how come they didn't kill
us there's more
what nothing they just dragged me here
and left me alive they're like oh we've
we've done enough
for one hard day's work i think i can
see his eyeball
yep we can see his eyeballs okay
well thank you man
for giving me your gun i really
appreciate it
i'm so sorry that i was asking you
questions why you needed to concentrate
and then you died
jesus christ
what the hell is wrong with this place
he looks is there another alive person
here
there's another alive person here
[Applause]
he's losing his hands
let me get back used to using a
controller it's been a while
what the hell
i hate having limited ammunition
i might die
interesting
i might not want to do this but i can
barricade for some reason
[Applause]
game what
why did you lure me over there what
that's right
i just barricaded myself in here
why
why did it give me the option to
barricade myself in with this
oh no why did i do this
unbarricade unbarricade
okay
jesus
there's nothing here
okay
oh my god oh my god
how many [ __ ] times
oh my god thank you thank god um
um um um
um
is it over
i'm gonna have to get better at eamonn
if there are any survivors out there
come to my
to louise's house near the fields
survivors
okay okay
so it takes about oh no no
a lot of bullets
i wasted one on the one outside as well
i don't need to do that
[ __ ] sake is it still out here
balance hands
there's one up there oh [ __ ] now
there's loads
oh my god they're [ __ ] everywhere
there's one my dad
why aren't they kidding me i think it's
a trap i think it's a trap i think it's
a trap i think it's a trap i think it's
a trap i think it's a trap
i want the herb i want the herb oh i'm
okay
no i'm not what am i doing
just take your thing
[Applause]
going down
i feel like i just don't know what i'm
doing because i can hear them everywhere
and i don't know like
when i should be on guard i guess
everywhere all the time
what happens will i be disguised now am
i
am i in disguise there's no end to them
i am in disguise
it's raining fire and i don't know why
it's fire
but it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hello hello yes still come in do come
in
welcome anytime
where am i going i do not know
where am i going i don't know but i got
a shotgun
oh
picked up some money
hello hello oh
i'm in my place
whoa jesus jesus jesus jesus jesus jesus
jesus
come on get down get down
come on get down on it
oh my god oh my god oh my god
this is the law
battle
i hope i don't have to fight you because
i have no ammo
[Applause]
oh thank god oh
thank god ethan is so sorry
poor man
what the hell just happened they just
all left
i think we scared him ethan good job
good man
here she is what
could i use that back now
oh geez
geez well
might as well go back around and make
sure i didn't forget anything
oh yeah baby
just went around here sorry i am
that annoying person yes i know
i just i need all the help i can get
basically in
i've if i've missed anything oh flower
oh maybe it's maybe it's out there
fair enough
oh it actually does create a cloud of
cover oh and i did miss something here
see
nothing really around here
oh what's this
it's that baby side
icon thing
okay now we're progressing don't worry
oh oh jesus i forget
sorry i always think the middle button
is gonna be
the start menu but it freaking fires the
gun i don't know why it does that
i'm gonna have to get used to that um
okay
i don't know why but i'm just seeing
darth vader
it's probably just me being stupid all
right
hello in life and in death
we give glory
uh hello you shouldn't be out here it's
not
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's you the child's father
child hey do you mean rose is she here
rose yes
she is in great danger since mother
miranda brought her to the village we
have fallen into
darkness what are you talking about the
monsters
the castle bell herald's danger
they're coming no
wait where's rose who's mother miranda
the bell tolls for us all
[Laughter]
okay so this is the same as the
demo right
yeah so i need to find a lockpick for
these things
the fabled monster wolves of old may
they come to eat our flesh when they
come to tear us apart
ooh it should have been a night like any
other
but then chris redfield came in and
destroyed our family
he took rose away shut me up right in
front of me
i was knocked out and now i'm in some
forests in the middle of nowhere
what the hell is going on and then
i found a village just outside the
forest but one of the villagers was
attacked and dragged up by some kind of
beast
i managed to survive these creatures and
an old woman told me rose is here
somewhere i need to find her before
those monsters get there too
don't worry i'm sure she's being
protected
well i mean for selfish means
but she's definitely they definitely
have a use for her at least
so i don't think that monsters are going
to get her
so if i remember rightly i just looked
at the map game
can't go up here no
can't go in here
[Music]
i should probably heal i've got a red
red
i want to get in there
oh good find
i just congratulated myself what i find
we offer these goats we offer these
goats of
warding to people to protect the village
and its people
any who break them shall feel mother
miranda's wrath
should i break it oh you should break it
come at me mother miranda come at me
i didn't put two and two together when i
first saw that in the demo
oh my gosh i totally did not see that
thank you so much juan
what a genius
treasure like precious
what is that oh sweet i can sell it i'm
very nice
there she is there she is
okay so annoying so i thought about
wearing this hat before i put my
headphones on i put my headphones on and
i was like oh
wait there is a floor in this clan
the giant hat
no ammo anything
okay
what's in these wells i guess if i find
whatever interacts with the wells then
maybe
i can pick up maybe they have like some
pickup in uh at the bottom of the well
you know they can dig it back up again
yes
oh no
i don't have enough ammo why don't we
keep doing that
huh
hell yeah
i i just i just have to do it straight i
can't
save them i just have i see something i
do it
i'm a very simple person um
let's see if we can craft anything
why can't i craft the shotgun
okay
should i just run for it guys i'm pretty
sure i can just run for it
close the door please
hey what are you doing here
stay back please don't hurt us
whoa it's okay i'm not gonna hurt you
i'm just glad to see normal people at
last have you seen any other survivors
no they're all in louise's house
and she's not answering in the gate is
locked quiet girl
he's an outsider
oh [ __ ] we're setting ducks in here
can your old man walk i'm not gonna
spoil it for you
one of the monsters cut him he's lost a
lot of blood we have to get into
louisiana
quiet there must be a way inside
stay here be quiet and don't move until
i get those gates open
well i just realized i have my bloodier
lights behind my head but whatever
thanks for following sheriff maggie
appreciate it uh
yes i will help you um
when do we get to finally go look down
here because
they're bloody everywhere
look in the toilet
i can't believe you don't get to keep
the volks
i guess that'd make the game far too
easy
come on it's clear hurry hurry
couldn't she
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
we'll be safe in here won't we safer
here than out there that's for sure
hey do you know anything about what's
going on here
it doesn't make any sense mother miranda
has always protected us
nobody's answer
father
we have to get inside wish i could just
take his machete
okay fine fine just hold on a bit longer
papa
hello anybody home
maybe a familiar voice louisa
open up it's me elena
stop shouting you'll draw the monsters
this a friend
stay back father for god's sake julian
let us in
no they'll smell the blood you'll
endanger us all my father will die out
here
that's not my problem what's going on
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these people oh
that's like the thumbnail
of malachi come now this way thanks for
the stupid chat
you're not from this village uh
no i'm ethan you lean go make yourself
useful and check the grounds
i said go
go julian if elena trusts you
then so do i come inside ethan
wait here i'll check on the others
[Music]
louisa they broke in again got more of
the livestock i don't think when we get
through winter at this rate ernest is
still missing too we can't find him
anywhere
has mother miranda abandoned us so like
has mother miranda just gone walkabouts
then
but the old lady said that this has been
happening since mother miranda
took rose here didn't she
beautiful
come inside the others are waiting
what the [ __ ] is this outsiders you're
gonna get us all killed
anton he helped leonardo and elena we
were doing fine by ourselves
please ethan take a seat
is this all that's left from your entire
village
all that's left all that's left
there is no one left a worthless
invalid a stupid
wailing [ __ ] and you
you drag a bloody man and an outsider in
here like it's nothing
and expect to be all safe there is no
safe every sorry bastard out there has
been ripped in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like her damn husband the bitter
succulent roxanna that's enough
this house i didn't realize that there
was something for generations dead
buddy there and trump played that you
are
all welcome and safe in here
whatever can someone please
tell me what the hell is going on here
we don't know
one day we were a quiet devout village
in the next
the monsters came and attacked us
and they they kept coming wait louisa
where is your husband did they
no no he he is out there
somewhere i still don't know whether
they're talking about the man that she
just
sent out whether her husband or someone
else you went to fetch help
let us pray for him she doesn't seem to
actually know what he is though
good idea come on
gather
let's all hold hands
great ones hear our voice
together as one in reverence we call on
thee
within the endless dark to deliver us
into faith's hands as the midnight moon
rises
on black wings so we make our sacrifice
and await the light at the end
in life and in death
we
now the tea should be ready come help me
elena please
that prayer i've heard it before there
was an old woman near the graveyard
some [ __ ] is crazy as a bag of rats
there is wisdom in her devotion though
and i hope it protected her as it shall
protect us
[Laughter]
what are you doing are you okay
no let me go
a side character
let him go i should spoil it
i'm so sorry father hey hey that wasn't
your father anymore
you did the right thing
[Applause]
elena elena no there's nothing you can
do
this entire place is collapsing
you couldn't save him he was already
gone
leave me alone no we're getting out of
here
together
i gotta get out of here
searching for the bullets searching for
some bullets
searching
she's just like crying in the background
um
if we could just get through this wall
don't worry ethan we will
let's pick up that herb for us though
yes please
everyone loves a good stew in this game
don't they
even mia at the start was playing
playing playing
making us do take the screwdriver out
the keyring oh
i yes remember what we need the
screwdriver for
that's very nice any more herbs
nope nothing in there nada
damn the fire's moving fast
um i know the fire's moving fast but can
i craft
some new items um
i mean to be fair i do have quite a few
bullets maybe i'm okay actually
never mind all is good
what are you thinking step back we can
bust out with this
excuse me um it wasn't evil seven vibes
running him over
are you all right um oh fine let me back
up again
the fire there isn't any time
oh
grab on hurry
let's move it's so dark don't worry
and try not to breathe in the smoke i
know
thank you ethan you're kind
i hope your family is safe i do too once
we get out of here maybe you'll get to
meet them
come on it'll hold
there that's our way out thank god
but what then the village is still full
of monsters
we can't fight them there's two of them
at a time okay
we don't talk like that we'll find a
safe house to put you in until i can
find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
that place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're father
elena no that's not him not anymore
he said my name father wait it's not
safe
oh it's such a shame
stay there
come on give me your hand you didn't say
her name so it's just a bit like
ethan go save your daughter
elena don't give up
reach for me
why is everyone dying on me
don't worry we'll we'll get rose don't
worry we'll get rose we'll get rose
sorry i can see you already chugged up
others i just it's
yeah i i played the demo so i've already
seen this bit before that's my
that's my excuse
thank you for super chat as well
this place is going mad
why the [ __ ] is this happening again
oh [ __ ]
it's so pretty though isn't it guys
yeah okay uh let's go
can we use the screwdriver for this yes
stop
is that is that mother miranda
or was he just shouting for like mother
around to help me
i don't know
that's the bells
okay so that sound means
yes dead yes
death has visited them all
and the phone looks like she's laughing
with her skull
what does that mean
she's smiling at us
um so i can't get up here
fine fine i guess we come back here then
wouldn't they think something was like
sus if
i guess this leads to the castle their
main
castle door had a massive ass demon on
it
eating someone
nothing but blood and death huh
um i can't actually remember
but i don't think we got any further
than that
um
that door in the demo so this should all
be new now
ah i love this environment
well well
i didn't think anyone was left you must
be
pretty tough huh
who the [ __ ] are you oh
you're not local even better
i didn't check out that door
see i don't know who that is i've been
trying to
keep information to a very minimum
on this game wait you're whining we're
almost there
he
the man is of no real use to anyone else
and my daughters do
so love entertaining forms
furthermore i can assure you if you
entrust the mortal to house
my daughters and i shall deliver to them
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up what where
you mean you'll screw around with them
in private words of fun in that
give them to me and i'll put on a show
that everybody can enjoy
oh so gauche what do we care for bread
and circuses she is
the man things suffering is assured yeah
cause a man's dick is cut off in the
castle blah blah
i've heard all your arguments some of
you were less persuasive than others
but i've made my decision
heisenberg the man's fate is in your
hands
mother miranda i must protest but there
isn't a miranda
but a child and his devotion to you is
questionable
give the mortal to me and i will ensure
he
is ready shut your dampers and don't be
a sore loser
you'll find your food somewhere else
quiet now
child adults are talking i'm the child
you're the one who's arguing with
miranda's decision she wouldn't know
responsibility if it was wealthy oh kid
glory
one day your head will actually take
your ego you might invite me
don't i get a singing silence
my decision is final there will be no
argument
remember from whence you came thanks
why don't the bubbles likens and
gentlemen we thank you for waiting
and now let the games begin
get ready
three two
one
run for your life i thought he was
giving me some
tips go right very nice
jesus what is that
fair enough
[Applause]
you're still alive
come on come on
[ __ ] hello
monsters my words
you truly are as strong as they say yes
oh you didn't think
so now it's time for the beauty
nothing like fresh american ground beef
i thought it was actually gonna die then
wait do those freaks have rose
maybe at the end it will um tell us that
actually ethan also has
um some of the fungus and that's why he
just can
take all the beatings in the world and
totally be fine
oh and lose his hand multiple times and
fingers
i wonder if he's gonna get them back
just like he got his hand back in the
first one
but my fingers aren't as severe as a
full hand
really oh thank god they didn't take my
weapons
they stupid
oh oh perfect so
i came in this way and that probably
would have been locked
well let's try again see how this time
goes
we are now certainly a wanted man
i mean everyone was fighting over us
oh at least back outside i wasn't
expecting that
oh i see
[Music]
yes yes i'll take a hat
oh i've just realized that actual real
people
not creepy at all not creepy at all are
they all real
people yeah they are yeah
i've been waiting for you mr winters
how do you know my name anyone who is
anyone has heard of the likes of you
a hero searching for his daughter
though i must say that castle arouses
suspicion
yeah and so do you
i am but a humble merchant here
oh forgive my manners call me the duke
now to business weapons ammunition
healing salves anything you desire
i can provide shotgun
welcome i have something special today
[Laughter]
oh it's because it came with the game
cue i got a little uh the raccoon
keychain thing to put on the gun that's
so cute
um
i don't need any hangar and am i
apparently i'm all good
should we just say okay let's let's save
it and then we'll
we can good day then wait wait can i see
[Music]
oh it's so funny there he is
oh that's so cute i love oh no my head's
in the way
oh you can't see now you can see if i do
this
look how cute i'll show you before i
end i'll show you properly anyway
let's carry on goodbye duke
[Music]
could rose be here
this looks pretty i completely forgot i
could have
sold my crystal thing to him but ugh
we'll do it next time okay you ready to
to smash some [ __ ] up
three daughters bella cassandra and
daniela
but they're not the three like
vampires are they no because one of them
is
lady d lady
or maybe she is one of those i don't
know i guess we'll find out
i feel kind of bad breaking all this
stuff i'm sure it's very expensive
i can't
january the 5th redneck delivery of one
male
3 females mother miranda
meeting with mistress dimitrisk
the duke business discussions so they do
know that he's here then
so that they're fine with him being here
because
they have business discussions with him
too so i guess he's just like a
a what would you call it like a
bystander like
he's not on any side but i still don't
understand
surely if they knew that he was going to
be helping us that they would not be
happy with that
man
need to be locked wait oh sorry sir
such a pretty place
[Music]
um
mask the angels blinded gaze i didn't
read the rest looking for
[Laughter]
roses
man blood
[Laughter]
um
i bring you fresh prey you are so kind
to me daughters
now let's take a look at him
wow well ethan winters
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
yes mother yes
[Laughter]
starting to go a little sting then let's
devour his man flesh quickly mother i am
the one who captured him
now now daughters first i must inform
mother miranda
but later well there will be enough
for everyone buddha
wait so tall
i hate bugs in horror games
can't stand them
those this is gonna be a pain
oh god i don't like it
oh even if porn
he always goes through so much turmoil
oh it's nice of them to leave that house
there
oh jeez i'm surprised
everything's there still works
yes i'm happy i did that very good find
hmm nothing like afternoon
tea with blood
ah apparently a lady d
is nine foot six that's crazy
that's crazy no
she actually i'm gonna have to look at
this look this up
no
thank you very much
and sell that and buy some nice things
oh oh i just spread that for no reason
whoops
just in case
where have they taken rows
mask the angel's blinded gaze and only
then
will you be saved
the angel of pleasure appreciates art's
best kept behind a gilded door
the angel of sadness weeps alone in a
deep dark place
the angel of happiness visit happiness's
vision
visage looks on words of wisdom
by her side again is it not just
apostrophe it doesn't matter
um the angel of anger looks down
in range from on high hello
okay well once i find one i know at
least roughly what i'm looking for
oh we meet again hello
why are you here where there's coin to
be made
and have you found your daughter no
if she is truly here the lady of the
castle would
have kept little rose in her private
chambers
would she not tell me to ask the very
same
why don't you take a look maybe you'll
get lucky
and speaking of looking care to make a
purchase
yes welcome
what are you buying just something an
old friend of mine used to say
which i probably will because i need to
these hands are more
dexterous than one might think
this is all an investment even have a
wonderful adventure
listen thanks
who is he though
norshtein's labyrinth a craftsman of the
late 19th century
norshtein was branded a heretic
in his homeland he wandered the lands
until he settled in a
shush please duke in a remote village
norshtein then created four labyrinths
the castle the house on the hill
the water wheel the iron tower upon
their completion he put a gun to his
temple
and took his own life
each labyrinth is unique and requires
its own specially crafted metal ball to
operate
each one contains crystallized human
remains
which are said to be norshtein's four
beloved wives
the labyrinths are their graves this is
so
interesting like
ah i wanna i wanna
i wanna check it out
but i can't yet
because i know that's not for this
that's for something else but how cool
is that
is it like a little world okay
and that is where i'm gonna leave
for now um
yeah that's why i'm gonna leave off for
now
juke are you okay
duke's a bit distraught that i'm uh
stopping playing for a bit what are you
doing
right um
yeah i'm gonna call that an evening
okay um make sure you subscribe and do
the bell
and all the things so that you know when
the next stream is
um yeah have a lovely day or evening